[Música]
vamos ahora a hablar de salud y para
ello nos acompaña ya en el estudio
Natalia plazas bienvenida buenos días
Rosa Natalia hoy que es el Día Mundial
del parkinson vamos a hablar sobre esta
dolencia que afecta a millones de
personas y que Según la OMS se ha
duplicado no su afectación entre la
población en los últimos años Así es
rosa como bien dices Sí es un día muy
importante para Resaltar un poco el
impacto que tiene esa enfermedad de como
decías en millones de personas pero
también en sus familias que normalmente
también se ven muy afectadas recordemos
también que es una enfermedad para la
que actualmente Y lamentablemente
todavía no se tiene cura para explorar
este tema nos acompaña hoy Carlos
Eduardo Pérez médico infectólogo y
asesor científico de France 24 doctor
bienvenido
de acuerdo a las estimaciones recientes
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
las más recientes para 2019 había 8,5
millones de personas sufriendo de esta
enfermedad qué objetivo tiene esta
jornada Y qué puede hacer para ayudar a
las personas que la sufren
Buenos días la OMS ha dicho nos ha
sensibilizado en este día para que las
entidades de salud
reconozcamos la enfermedad porque esta
enfermedad se diagnostica tardíamente
para hacerlo el reconocimiento no
solamente por los especialistas de
neurología sino por todos los grupos
médicos a través de la salud para poder
ofrecer un tratamiento que estos
tratamientos y se hacen tempranamente
mejoran mucho la calidad de vida de
nuestros pacientes entonces Este es un
día muy importante porque sensibiliza
hacia una enfermedad que produce una
alteración motora pero que interviene
Luego tempranamente si puede ofrecer
alternativas terapéuticas que le ofrecen
a las personas mejor calidad y desempeño
en sus actividades cotidianas
doctor Buenos días le saludo también
antes de los estudios de France 24 como
ustedes lo decía sabemos que el
parkinson afecta a la capacidad motora y
también a la capacidad mental de las
personas que lo padecen Pero qué otros
síntomas puede presentar esta enfermedad
Y por qué se está multiplicando en los
últimos años
Esta es una enfermedad que tiene una
afectación variable puede producir
enfermedades digamos se conocen cinco
fases una donde hay una alteración leve
de una parte cuerpo otra cuando hay una
alteración ya en el aula el puede
referir la marcha una tercera fase
cuando altera las situaciones cotidianas
como comer como alimentarse como ir al
baño una cuarta cuando ya la afectación
para caminar para hablar es
impide se impide en estas personas una
forma importante y una última donde la
él lo lleva la postración esta variedad
de síntomas motores se puede afectar o
no la alteración cognitiva pues llevan a
las personas a un deterioro de su
calidad de vida pero como lo he dicho si
uno interviene tempranamente hay
alternativas médicas que pueden permitir
recuperar esta enfermedad no es curable
pero es controlable y tiene opciones de
tratamiento doctor y la OMS también ha
dicho que la discapacidad y la muerte
por esta enfermedad está aumentando más
rápido que cualquier otro trastorno
neurológico que se sabe de se sabe a qué
se debe este aumento
digamos que no hay una precisión porque
se está incrementando pero primero se
está reconociendo más la enfermedad
digamos que muchas personas pasaban sin
el diagnóstico segundo Al haber mayor
accesibilidad los sistemas de salud pues
se reconoce que hay más número de
enfermos sin embargo sí se ha notado es
incremento en el número de casos es el
trastorno neurológico que afecte como
normales que más afecta la humanidad
pero lo interesante de esto es que hay
alternativas de tratamiento que se
pueden ofrecer tempranamente si bien los
neurólogos son los médicos encargados
del tratamiento todos los grupos de
salud tenemos que diagnosticar
reaccionar y identificar claramente que
cuando una persona tiene dificultad del
habla de la marcha puede tener un
trastorno de parkinson para poderlo
dirigir a un tratamiento y a un médico
especializado y ofrecer en las etapas
tempranas el tratamiento para mejorar su
calidad de vida una persona con
parkinson viven los mismos años que si
una persona que no tiene parkinson la
calidad de vida depende la intervención
terapéutica y doctor Cómo usted nos dice
hay tratamientos pero de momento no hay
cura le pregunto qué investigación es en
marcha hay que puedan aportar una cierta
Esperanza tanto a los pacientes como a
los familiares de personas que tienen
parkinson
tal vez en los últimos 20 años había un
avance no solamente en tratamientos
farmacológicos cada vez son más precisos
recordemos que la enfermedad de
parkinson es un déficit de un
neurotransmisor que se llama dopamina
que permite las conexiones cerebrales
entonces hay medicamentos que reemplazan
esa dopamina esa función que hace para
poder recuperar la movilidad pero
también hay unas intervenciones
quirúrgicas hay unas intervenciones
detalladas sobre los Centros donde se
producen estos movimientos anormales que
cuando se hacen intervenciones
quirúrgicas de alta precisión se puede
controlar la enfermedad no solamente son
tratamientos farmacológicos sino
quirúrgicos que se le ofrecen a las
personas y cada vez hay más alternativas
terapéuticas que le podemos ofrecer Cuál
es la clave diagnóstico temprano
intervención temprana y manejo
especializado sí doctora justamente
ahora que estamos hablando de
medicamentos y de las distintas terapias
existentes también existe una
preocupación respecto a la cobertura que
es desigual entre los distintos países
incluso hay algunos medicamentos que son
digamos los primarios para hacer
para dar respuesta a las a los síntomas
más importantes de esta enfermedad sin
embargo muchos de estos medicamentos no
se encuentran accesibles para toda la
población debido a su precio o ni
siquiera o ni siquiera están disponibles
en algunos países que se debe pedir a
los gobiernos para garantizar que tanto
los pacientes como sus familias tengan
todas las herramientas disponibles
no importa hacer el diagnóstico hacemos
intervención los gobiernos deben tener
políticas sobre la eh acondicionamiento
estos medicamentos estos medicamentos no
son medicamentos algunos son muy nuevos
otros no lo son Pero hay una
intervención temprana que tiene que
ofrecer a los pacientes es decir que
esta accesibilidad a los recursos
terapéuticos debe ser universal porque
los pacientes con parkinson tienen de
tratamiento pero no puede ser esa opción
de tratamiento diferente por nacer un
país o por nacer en otro país la
accesibilidad de ser Universal El
llamado que hoy se hace Haz que
reconozcamos la enfermedad que hayan
políticas públicas claras mundiales y
locales y regionales para accesibilidad
de tratamiento ofrecer tratamiento de
apoyo soportes psicológico medidas de
rehabilitación e intervenciones
terapéuticas tempranas un gran día para
reconocer una enfermedad a muchas
personas que lo padecen nuestra
solidaridad y adelante porque hay
opciones de tratamiento para su manejo
doctor Muchas gracias por toda esta
divulgación a sobre el parkinson en el
Día Mundial dedicado a esta enfermedad
Natalia Muchísimas gracias por traernos
acercarnos a esta cuestión nos vemos en
otro momento más adelante Gracias Rosa